These people we keep hearing from, uh, who,
uh, chase Barry Weiss out to the New York times who chase Suzanne more out
of the guardian in the UK, uh, who, uh,
who cry when they learn that a new Jordan Peterson book is going to be published
and pay their salary the next year, this is a generational thing.
And I don't know at this stage that we can see it's completely a political
movement.
It's some kind of counter revolution that has been going on.
It believes as you know,
that speech is harm and harm is not harm,
but silence is violence and violence is fine.
It has a set of mantras. And I simply think it won't stop until it,
it hits the reality of this light.
[Inaudible].
It was to me that something very wrong has happened with your media. Uh,
not just the broadcast media, but the print media. Uh it's it's um,
I don't wanna get stuck on it, but I mean, every country I know about,
I know the New York times and can prove that it's lying. Uh,
so I can't read it because any country, I don't know very much about,
I wouldn't, I would assume that they're lying, but I wouldn't know exactly how,
um, so,
so you've got a very deep problem in your legacy media.
And, uh, obviously a lot of people have been pointing that out for a long time.
Um, and I wonder now, if, if Trump does go, uh, those,
those papers and magazines will be in want of an enemy. And, uh,
often as you know, that's,
that's the worst thing for a person is if they lose their enemy. Um,
but yeah, so we, we, we, we don't have that media from the, the, the,
the problem we do all have, it seems to me, and you've written about this as,
you know,
as well as anyone is that people have become very bad at listening to a contrary
opinion. And that is,
I think that's gonna prove to be a generational thing that there just
is. Uh, I speak 24 hours after the news came out. Uh,
Jordan Peterson, as publishers in Canada, that that'd been yeah.
Wailing and gnashing of teeth, actual tears.
At the staff meeting when some,
some employees of, uh, paint, uh,
hang around half, uh, uh, the, the, the,
that some of the employees of penguin discovered that they were going to, uh,
publish another book, uh,
next year by a man who's actually earned them their salaries. Um.
He sold probably about 7 million copies last I heard.
So he floats in many ways, the entire ability for them to,
to choose all these other books that aren't going to do quite as well.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's only because of him that they can publish the sort of intersectional
fictional team list. Um, yeah, no, the, these, um,
this, these people we keep hearing from,
uh, who, uh, chase Barry Weiss to the New York times,
who chase Suzanne more out of the guardian in the UK, uh,
who, uh,
who cry when they learn that a new Jordan Peterson book is going to be published
and pay their salary the next year, this is a generational thing.
And I don't know at this stage that we can see it's completely a political
movement.
It's some kind of counter revolution that has been going on.
It believes as you know,
that speech is harm and harm is not harm,
but silence is violence and violence is fine.
It has a set of mantras. And I simply think it won't stop until it,
it hits the reality of this life.
I don't know when that will happen. I just hope it happens very, very soon.
I think that everybody who cried at the meeting,
I said this this morning on social media,
everybody who cried at the meeting and said that they didn't want to be at the
publishing house that published John Peterson, bang Sally out next morning,
your job is advertised so many smart young men and women should be in the
publishing business and have, and have a very,
very good reason to be so and could be excellent in their chosen profession.
And they're not because these people who have no right to be in a publishing
house are in it and, and clogging up and making everyone stupid.
And so there's the, these people that has to be fun.
We have to make sure that media companies and others are
not held hostage by the stupidest youngest.
Most ignorant people in the room.
Is the biggest problem there that these companies,
once they fall under the spell, I mean, you wrote a book about this,
but once they fall under the spell,
they bring in the diversity and inclusion department.
Their HR department is teaching people to watch out for white supremacism and
all of these things. Thus, they destroy their own entities.
I'm completely with you. And, and I run businesses.
If I had employees that were upset with me over my decision-making goodbye,
goodbye, that's it. You know, but,
but isn't that the bigger problem that once you've let this thing in,
in many ways, you're, you're the people, you're the very people.
You let the bad guys in,
and now they're in the house running around and what can you do?
Well, what you can do is to reassert your rights as an adult.
What I see everywhere in America in particular is the
complete retreat of being adults. Let me give you an example.
I'm sure you've heard many times. I,
thankfully nobody has actually said it to my face or they'd have it coming to
them. But I have heard a lot of people told in recent years,
educate yourself.
Everybody who says educate yourself in my observation
is without exception, the dumbest person I have seen speaking,
they have no right to go around being the stupidest
person in the room, telling everyone else to educate themselves.
They don't mean educate yourself.
They mean agree with me or else. Well, here's a suggestion.
The adults say, no, you do not know anything.
You're 23.
You've got a totalistic view of the universe that you're going to discover quite
soon. At some point in your life is wildly wrong.
And you are making yourself unemployable.
Here is your unemployment form your jobs up through advert tomorrow.
That's what the adults have to do. I'm fed up by the way. You've see.
So CEOs and heads of companies and all sorts of things that it's ever since the
madness of crowds came out. I find they signed all up to me.
They whisper up to me and tell me that this is what they have.
And I'm fed up with the whispers and the is, I'm fed up with the adults,
the people at the tops of their careers, all of whom are bearing down.
It's like that video that went viral. The other day of this,
you saw this weird LGBTQ plus kid kid thing,
and literally they're bowing down and worshiping the new
God thing,
which is the stupidest person in the room.
And I'm not up for the opportunity costs society that that involves. Um,
and I think nobody else should be either.
And I'm fed up over the grass and I'm fed up conservatives grousing about it.
This is the stuff that we've been talking about for years. So it is nice.
You, you, you, you and I, and many other people,
we write books about these things. We, we can write columns.
We can do shows about it and all of that stuff.
And then we get what I think you just said is the most frustrating part,
which is people at companies and people in their own private lives who are just
still simply afraid to do anything. So then they'll, Oh, Douglas,
I loved your book, but I don't want to take a picture with you or, you know,
something like that. Like you're, you're still too out there and too scary that,
that in many ways is the, is the most frustrating part, don't you think?
Uh, well, I think they usually love photos anyway. Yeah.
Uh, no, they just don't want to post them on Facebook.
What I find is, uh,
that they don't realize that what they
are,
what they are bringing in is mental and moral asbestos.
They don't realize that it's toxic to everyone in the atmosphere who has to
breathe. It.
The job of the adults is to strip the moral and mental
asbestos from the building fast as possible.
And if that means stripping a whole load of under thirties
out then fine,
there are a lot of very smart under thirties who could fill those positions
and would do a great and noble a job at it.
But it is absolutely incumbent upon people as you know what I argue
in the madness of crowds to understand that that is what we are dealing with.
Once you play the diversity and equity game,
you are infusing the lungs of your
employees with this asbestos,
and you have to get it out. Now.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.